So we've put the equation of
a line into point-slope form.
So we have as y minus y one
equals m times x minus x one.
I can actually go from this point-slope
version of the equation of the line,
to a more familiar and
easier to read slope-intercept version.
And I'm going to do that by
multiplying out this side and
getting Y by itself on the left side.
So the first thing I'm going to do is
distribute this two-thirds, which gives
me two-thirds x minus two-thirds times
nine, and that is nine over one.
Actually let me erase nine and
write it as three times three
because then I can simplify here.
Okay, let's continue.
Now I have y minus eight equals
two-thirds x minus well,
two times three over one,
so just minus six.
I can now add eight to both sides and
what do you know?
I have my equation in
slope-intercept form, and in fact,
maybe you can now tell me,
what is the y-intercept of this line?